commissioner how are you this morning
I'm great good morning Dan good morning
good morning do you have an off season
not much anymore because the season
ended then the draft was last week
obviously the award show is tonight
summer league stuff free agency starts
July 1st then we go into the summer
league we've got a WNBA so it's great to
be busy but not much of an All Seasons
but is everybody trying to look at the
blueprint of the NFL not that you can be
the NFL in popularity but that they
stretch it out for a good 11 months you
want to have top you want to be part of
the conversation even in the offseason
is that your goal we didn't set out that
way it's more a function of the calendar
and when I mean we've talked about
frankly moving the draft even later in
the year because if we had had a longer
finals in the years where we end up with
seven games it's such a mad rush into
the draft which comes only a few days
after game seven so ideally we would
have moved it later but when we
consulted with our teams because if we
push the draft later it would push free
agency back later it would push our
summer league back later Plus on top of
that there's things that we don't have
control over like summer competitions
whether they be World Cup games and
basketball Olympic summer's so it it's
actually it's not our intention we'd
actually like to give people more of a
rest both both league office people
working around the year and players as
well but but again it's more function of
the calendar if you end an MVP vote who
would you vote for this season yes I'm
not responding why wait wait you watch
the game you love the game why can't you
have an opinion on that
I have an opinion but I love them all
and I honestly I I have my own view but
don't think would be appropriate for me
to answer but on that I love all three
nominees all three finalists are
fantastic players it's not like you love
your kids all the same because I have
four kids I don't love them all the same
Commissioner I'll tell you who I would
get my MVP to in my family so this is
your family your share
the problem I only have one daughter
Louise and I ended the complete love so
I don't know how to make those kind of
decisions that you folks with four kids
do so she's your LeBron is what you're
saying the end Michael I in my heart joy
well of course of course
okay I got a couple of things here this
is what I want to understand with the
designation with the all-nba team we
still have a center to forwards and two
guards but I look at the center's
they're not among the top 15 players in
the NBA but there's things attached to
this with Gordon Hayward and Paul George
who are better than DeAndre Jordan or
Rudy Gobert they they don't make the
all-nba team why do we have a center
designation when we've almost prided
ourselves in the fact that nobody really
has positions anymore it's a very fair
question and because as you know we
eliminated the center designation for
all-star balloting and so there is an
inconsistency with all NBA and the
reason we left it for all NBA it was
more a function of contracts that are
already been negotiated where there are
bonuses and incentives set for winning
awards based on being the center and the
desert and an all-nba not all NBA
consideration that comes from being a
center I think it's one of the things we
should consider changing if we were
going to do it though
I think just as a function of contracts
that that were already entered into we
have to announce it and then change it
two or three seasons later but it but
you're right and it's not and and it's a
little different with all-star because
the exhibition game so there weren't all
the same incentives tied to specific
positions for all-star but you know I I
don't have a better reason than that it
was just it was just it was based
entirely on the fact that contracts had
been written and there were incentives
based on being a the designation that
came from being Center yeah just
grandfathered in but I think as you move
forward because you know Gordon Hayward
could leave Utah because of this Paul
George could leave Indiana looks like
because of that that they're not going
to get there max deals I also wanted to
ask you you can write what you think is
the ideal rule for the one and done two
and done coming out of high school if I
gave you that autonomy how would you how
would you
look that you think is the right way to
go with how we have these kids coming
into college or coming into the NBA and
another very fair question so view any
of you'd asked me that a year ago I
would have said if I didn't have to
negotiate this with the Union I would
raise the minimum age to 20 from 19 and
of course it at you know it was in 2004
18 and we collectively bargained with
Union raise it to 19 but they've
historically opposed going to 20 my view
has changed and I don't have a great
answer but the reason my view has
changed is for example you know I've
talked about this before if you look at
Ben Simmons documentary you know about
what his year was like in school at LSU
and no knock on LSU but his bright young
man he was saying I'm only here because
I'm being forced to defer going to the
NBA for a year and you an NCAA
tournament didn't seem all that
important to him and it may ultimately
have been a lost year in his development
because he's not fully engaged in school
he's not fully engaged in basketball in
part because of very understandable NCAA
regulations on how often coaches can
interact with their teams limitations in
the summer etc and then I look at some
of the players coming in internationally
who are becoming full-time professional
basketball players as we see in global
soccer at 16 years old and they're on a
in some cases a develop better
development program and also a more
holistic one even in terms of injury
prevention and better monitoring of
everything they're doing and better
control over them so where does that
leave me it's to me it's no longer an
issue whether we go from 19 to 18 or 19
to 20 I think it means that we as the
NBA have do something we've historically
avoided which is getting more involved
in youth basketball if you sit with the
folks from Nike or Under Armour or
adidas they can tell you who the top 100
14 year-olds are in the world and
there's a fairly close correlation
between the top 100 at 14 and the top
100 at 18 but is it bad
our table though that you can that kids
are going to be able to come out of high
school right to the NBA is that is that
a possible up in here it it's a possible
option it's on the table I would add
into the mix though what is you know our
Development League now known as the
jeely going forward I think that creates
an opportunity as well and maybe that
becomes an alternative it right now you
can go into our Development League at 18
we don't talk about that a lot because I
mean for most of the top young men
college even if all you care about is
basketball and you're not focused on
your education college still seems to be
a better alternative for them and
getting the exposure and getting the
development in these great programs and
by the way I don't mean to diminish in
any way their need for education but
just being a realist here that there
they're not even a lot of them aren't
even spending a full one year in college
and and their entire focus is becoming
an mba player so that question it
becomes if we allow players to get
drafted at 18 do they go first into our
G League do some portion of the players
go directly into our G League that's why
I don't I mean I'm just being honest I
don't I don't have a secret plan in the
drawer I think that but my thinking has
evolved on this subject and I think it's
something that that even before we sit
back down with the Union you're right
the fair question from the Union could
be what is it that you want you know
before we even start negotiating and and
right now you know we have our
competition committee focused on it we
have an owners meeting in July we're
looking at a lot of the data in terms of
sort of sort of injuries we're also I'm
hearing from team orthopaedics now that
who've been around the league for a long
time they're seeing wear and tear
injuries among 19 and 20 year olds that
they used to see among 28 and 29 year
olds and I think that's also a function
in part not all AAU is bad but in in
many cases these young men are playing
or teenagers are playing far too many
games you know where there's a I've said
it before there's a there's a pitch
count in Little League
but in basketball you have often have
kids playing eight games in a weekend
and there's no incentive to raise their
hand and say my knees too swollen or
sore my ankle hurts because every game
seemingly is important in terms of
college scouting talking to the
Commissioner of the NBA and silver big
awards ceremony coming up tonight
the concerns over tanking I love that
the Sixers say trust the process but it
really dresses it up when all you're
doing is just trying to lose game you
know Mark Cuban came on my show recently
and said look once we were out of it we
were tanking to see if we could get in a
better position for the lottery how do
we prevent tanking um you know first I
did I think mark was being provocative
and I've talked to to him about it since
then I mean if you look at his record
over the end of the season I mean I
think there's a big difference as you
and I maybe would use the word tanking
which is teams intentionally losing as
opposed to putting young players out
there players you need to make decisions
about in deciding whether those guys you
want to renew whether those guys you
want to trade etc so you know I just
putting Mark Cuban's comment aside for a
second I think he was though where he
was being provocative was something he's
said to me before which is this is an
area that League needs to take a fresh
look at because you know we put the
lottery in place precisely for this
reason and that was well over 30 years
ago because teams seemingly had this
huge incentive to finish at the bottom
because the value of these draft picks
is so high and we've tinkered with the
draft lottery I think almost five times
you know in the last 30-plus years but
we're still not at the point where it's
frankly working and I recognize it's
always going to be a balance as long as
draft picks
especially top graphics are so
strategically important for teams
they're going to have an incentive in
certain cases to be at the bottom but I
think I've looked at a bunch of
different proposals you know everything
from we should block in from when a team
record and you know in march and that
should be the order of the draft people
have suggested you know just flat-out
changing the odds you know in terms you
know changing the you know making making
the curve flatter what if you could only
be in a section a certain number of
years like it like Philadelphia could be
in back-to-back years you can't be in
three years in a row that that's you
know the problem is if a team is frankly
genuinely bad I mean the purpose of the
draft of course is to help them rebuild
and to help improve them and so you end
up in a situation where a team may be to
no fault to their own they're not part
of any process but they've been unlucky
they've had injuries players haven't pin
out and the question is what is the
purpose of the draught and if you're
saying we're going to we're going to
just create some bright-line rule that
you can't be in the lottery three years
in the row whatever it is you know if
that team going to be sort of locked
into being bad but but that just a quick
reaction to it I think that's something
we have to look at as well I would just
say right now it's it's not working and
I mean you look at European soccer the
other end of the spectrum relegation
relegation no I mean it is a problem you
know in this league when you know
there's a bit of a free rider issue too
because in all the major leagues in the
United States each team gets an equal
share of the national television money
whether or not you're the champion or
you finished 30th in terms of the
standings and so also financially there
there's not a great incentive and when I
some of our owners also own clubs in in
the in the Premier League for example I
mean relegation you know if it
completely changes the financial
framework of your team sets you back you
know maybe for a decade in some cases so
what about if you did is so much
incentive what if you said once you're
eliminated from the playoffs
then the clock is on starts ticking that
the best record then gets the most
ping-pong balls out of the teams that
have been eliminated therefore the rest
of the season you're going to compete as
hard as you can and there's a reward at
the end of the rainbow for being a bad
team that is just not played that well
it's an interesting idea and I think
it's one we should look at too I mean
some people have said well then what's
the incentive for those players they're
playing incredibly hard so that a team
the better their performance is the more
likely they may get replaced by a
drastic but I again I there's a lot of
smart people in this league I you know
and a lot of smart commentators like
thank you have thank you great ideas and
then I mean it and they come in through
social media I get lots of them come
directly into my email my inbox so III
know there's a problem now I think this
is why Mark said what he said on your
show and it's something that again
we've experimented with so many
different approaches over the years it's
why we have the lottery but we're not in
a great place when team seemingly don't
have an incentive to win it you know at
the end of the season or even to run on
a process for an entire season as we've
seen if I said anything on their show
that you actually got angry about that
got to your desk that I that you're
angry about no no why am i acting angry
no no no no Sternwood but but but Stern
Stern would act that way no matter what
no no no Adam you're fine it's it David
would always let me know if I did
something wrong
it's the name Stern I know like he just
lives up to it he has to be that way can
you help the Knicks Adam can you do
anything no you cannot they cannot be
helped is what you're saying the
commissioners said yeah no I'm only
saying within my role as commissionable
okay I it's not for me to get involved
in the management of the Knicks okay but
you're not saying watch it thanks my
dear when I walk the streets of New York
I'm it's probably the number one thing
that fans say to me but I think Jim
Dolan wrote a song called fix the Knicks
so he's aware of that as well
have fun tonight and good luck with your
private MVP vote of Russell Westbrook
thanks Dan great talker
okay commissioners that's the
Commissioner Adam Silver right there the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience